in berlin begrüße ich jetzt carsten
linnemann den stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden von cdu und csu im
deutschen bundestag herr lindemann
erleichterungen für alle verspricht das
wahlprogramm der union so weit schon
durchgesickert abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlages entlastung
kleinerer und mittlerer einkommen
entlastung der unternehmen keine
steuererhöhungen und das alles bei einem
so hoch verschuldeten bundeshaushalt wie
wir das im moment haben wer soll das
eigentlich bezahlen
guten morgen herr rasen ich grüße sie
wenn wir kein wachstum bekommen können
wir uns das nicht leisten das ist die
wahrheit und die gehört ausgesprochen
wenn wir eine rezessive phase rutschen
wird das was wir wollen nicht umgesetzt
werden auch das gehört zur wahrheit zur
klarheit und deswegen brauchen wir
wachstum und dieses programm gibt diesen
wachstumsschub davon bin ich überzeugt
corona hat gezeigt dass wir jetzt eine
mentalität in deutschland des machens
brauchen einfach mal machen lassen nicht
sagen es geht nicht weil sondern es geht
die leute einfach mal los laufen lassen
die idee haben und nicht stoppen und
diesen geist atmet dieses programm damit
schaffen wir wachstum und damit können
wir die dinge finanzieren wenn sie sagen
da steht alles unter einem
finanzierungsvorbehalt dann heißt das
doch aber eigentlich das ist ein
wunschprogramm und kein wahlprogramm das
heißt finanzierungsvorbehalt ich bin in
die politik gegangen um wachstum mit zu
generieren ich selber kann es nicht es
können nur die arbeitnehmer und die
arbeitgeber aber ich kann den rahmen
schaffen
wir haben es doch bereits gezeigt nach
der finanzkrise zehn jahre lang wachstum
in deutschland und genau das müssen wir
jetzt auch schaffen das schaffen wir
aber nur wenn wir entfesseln und dieser
teil steht auch im wahlprogramm und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass wir das auch
schaffen und deswegen unterstütze ich
nicht nur armin laschet sondern auch
dieses programm das wir jetzt mit voller
kraft in die zukunft gehen
sie gehen also davon aus dass wir
wachstum bekommen nun befinden wir uns
ja aber noch mitten in der pandemie in
anderen europäischen staaten sieht es
gerade wieder düsterer aus die delta
variante kommt und könnte möglicherweise
den nächsten lockdown uns im herbst
bescheren
das würde doch dann bedeuten nach
ihrem wahlprogramm den gürtel für alle
enger schnallen müssen wir rasen
ich glaube wir sollten aufhören
szenarien zu zeichnen was wäre wenn
erst war es die alpha variante jetzt die
delta variante wir brauchen optimismus
und zukunft zuversicht und ich kenne die
virologen alle von hendrik strikt bis
wem auch immer die alle sagen jetzt
lasst uns keine panik machen und dafür
werde ich auch wir haben jetzt diesen
sommer wir müssen uns vorbereiten klar
dass die schulen ganz normal wieder
stattfinden können aber ich warne vor
panik wir müssen jetzt mal optimismus
ausstrahlen wir sind durch diese
pandemie gekommen
wir haben vieles richtig gemacht ja es
ist auch vieles deutlich geworden was im
argen liegt und die antwort darauf zu
geben dass versuchen übrigens auch im
wahlprogramm dass wir die richtigen
lehren aus dieser krise ziehen
gut dann gehen wir mal von ihrem
optimismus aus markus söder sagt 20 23
möchte er einen ausgeglichenen
bundeshaushalt sehen ist das mit ihrem
programm der unter normalen bedingungen
zu machen können sie das versprechen
versprechen kann man in der politik gar
nichts und ich wäre auch vorsichtig mit
versprechungen die menschen sind zu oft
enttäuscht worden
aber natürlich muss die union als
volkspartei den anspruch haben dass wir
so schnell wie möglich die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten
politiker politik auch der staat braucht
regelbindung gesehen doch hier und da
wenn es keine regel bindung gibt dann
gibt man die eine oder andere milliarde
vielleicht mehr aus als man ausgeben
würde wenn die schuldenbremse in kraft
ist das sage ich auch selbstkritisch
deswegen werde ich alles daran setzen
dass wir so schnell wie möglich wieder
die schuldenbremse die im grundgesetz
fest verankert ist einheiten man ist
sich ja zumindest nach außen hin in
vielen punkten schnell einig gewesen
beamten konnte keine einigkeit erzielt
werden nämlich bei der mütter renter
rente da wollte ja markus söder von der
csu gerne schon ein schritt weiter gehen
schreibt das jetzt ins eigene
wahlprogramm rhein ist das eigentliche
etwas was die harmonie trügt
das war in den vergangenen jahren schon
immer so dass die bayern einen bayern
plan hatten das ist ihr gutes recht
entscheidend ist die geschlossenheit
dass wir geschlossen sind und wenn man
über die eine oder andere frage mal eine
differenzierte meinung hat dann ist das
doch okay wir können doch nicht so tun
als ob wir alles gleich sehen und alle
politiker bei der mutter rente ist es so
dass sie meines erachtens nicht
zielgerichtet ist die mütter rente ja
bekommen auch mütter sage ich mal dies
nicht so nötig haben und ich bin für
eine sozialpolitik die zielgerichtet ist
die den menschen hilft dies genau
brauchen zum beispiel die
erwerbsgeminderten das sind menschen die
möchten gerne arbeiten können aber nicht
weil sie körperlich oder wie auch immer
gehemmt sind und für die etwas zu tun
das muss meines erachtens zentral seien
nicht politik mit der gießkanne sondern
zielgerichtet renten und sozialpolitik
jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
bundestagswahlen im september und man
kann ja davon ausgehen wenn die cdu
weiter regieren möchte muss sie es mit
einem koalitionspartner machen
schauen wir uns mal die grünen an da
wird ja viel diskutiert klimaneutralität
da sagt die cdu 20 45 soll deutschland
klimaneutral werden die grünen sagen 20
35 eine riesenlücke muss ich wenn ich
mich ums klima sorge dann grün wählen
nein ich habe auch ein problem mit dem
wettbewerb die menschen ich meine ziele
können wir uns alle geben entscheidend
ist dass wir die ziele erreichen und wir
sind der festen überzeugung dass wir das
ziel 2045 erreichen und zwar mit
technologieoffenheit mit innovation
hier in deutschland müssen die produkte
herstellen die umwelttechnologien die
international nachgefragt werden so wie
das in den vergangenen jahrzehnten im
maschinenbau war im anlagenbau in der
elektroindustrie in der chemie das muss
unser anspruch sein
darauf setzen wir und dann werden wir
das auch schaffen gepaart mit dem
emissionshandel der auf europäischer
ebene
meines erachtens schnell ausgeweitet
werden muss wer als deutschland werden
es alleine nicht schaffen wir brauchen
europa und auch darauf setzt die union
das sagt carsten lindemann
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
von cdu und csu im deutschen bundestag
herzlichen dank nach berlin für das
gespräch ich danke ihnen herr rasen
schönen tag noch